Professor Langdon
Hammer: Second Auden
lecture.
I was reading last time from
poems from the '30s,
those love poems:
"Lay Your Sleeping Head,
My Love," and "This Lunar
Beauty."
The ballad that I read for you,
"As I Walked Out One Evening,"
also a poem about love,
also comes from the later '30s.
It is collected though in this
book called Another Time,
a book Auden published in 1940.
And I wanted to,
well, let's see,
I'm afraid I've got my order
all mixed up here.
I wanted to show you just the
table of contents of this book
because it has a number of
masterpieces in it that you are
reading.
It's also significant that it's
organized in the way that it is.
The first section is called,
humbly I guess or practically,
"People and Places" and it
includes in it the poem I'll be
discussing shortly,
"Musée des Beaux Arts."
There're another couple of
sections, a section called
"Lighter Poems" that includes
all kinds of song forms:
"Refugee Blues,"
different kinds of blues,
and some kind of Gothic,
satirical ballads – "Miss
Gee,"
"James Honeyman" – poems that
are antecedents for a song like
"Maxwell's Silver Hammer."
This is the kind of thing Auden
was writing.
And then there's also something
else called "Occasional Poems,"
and in this box Auden has put
"Spain 1937,"
that great political poem from
the Civil War,
and these poems that I'll be
discussing today:
"In Memory of W.B.
Yeats" and "In Memory of
Sigmund Freud."
I wanted to call attention to
this book, first of all because
it shows us these poems embedded
in the actual context in which
they first appeared,
but also to point out the way
in which Auden has organized his
book.
That is to say,
he has thought of his poems as
belonging to specific categories
and placed them accordingly.
And they have different genres,
different forms suitable to
different purposes and
occasions.
And this is very much the way
in which Auden imagines himself
as a poet, I think,
that is, someone writing with a
kind of technical mastery with
access to a whole repertoire of
traditional forms which are
suitable to different purposes
and different occasions.
This general perspective on his
work is related to the topic
that I introduced in discussing
"As I Walked Out One Evening,"
and that is the whole question
of perspective in Auden.
You remember I talked about how
that poem seems to include,
well, at least three different
perspectives:
that is,
the quoted song of the lover
who tells his beloved that he
will love her until the end of
time;
then, there's the voice of the
clocks who speak from the point
of view of time and correct his
claims;
and then finally there's a kind
of narrative voice that seems to
frame the whole thing with that
image of the river running on.
As in that poem,
Auden seems to be able to
incorporate in his poetry
multiple perspectives,
each of which comment on or are
framed or conditioned by the
others, but each of which has
its independent truth,
you could say.
This is a topic that we'll
explore more today looking at
other poems.
I wanted to show you some
photographs.
In the 1930s during the
Japanese-Chinese War,
a prelude to the Second World
War,
Auden went with his friend
Christopher Isherwood to China
and they created a book together
called Journey to a War
which includes Isherwood's prose
and Auden's poetry.
It's quite a remarkable book.
It also includes photographs
which are presented in an
interesting way.
We have here two different
photographs of boys,
boys who are classified here as
"soldiers" and "civilians" and
then grimly are identified as
"with legs" and "without."
There's a kind of interest in
these photographs and in their
presentation of how--in the ways
in which in war who we are is a
matter of perspective and point
of view.
The war gave Auden and
Isherwood an opportunity to
experience what it was like to
be on the ground when planes are
overhead bombing you,
and here's one photograph of
that condition.
And here is another
illustration of this general
point I wanted to make.
There are unidentified corpses
under blankets there.
There are then scattered human
remains and debris.
And the one photograph is
identified as "The Innocent" and
the other as "The Guilty."
Well, the great poem on this
general theme in Auden's work is
"Musée des Beaux Arts."
It is a poem that Auden wrote
after returning from China in
December, I believe,
1938, contemplating a return to
the United States where he had
visited a short time before,
contemplating,
in fact, expatriation;
also, contemplating an imminent
war, a world war that would
extend the horror that he had
witnessed in China to all of
Europe and beyond.
Suffering, in other words,
was on his mind,
and it's the subject,
or rather, art's relation to
suffering is the subject of this
poem.
The poem has as its occasion a
visit to the Musée des Beaux
Art in Brussels where Auden saw
among other works this painting,
"The Fall of Icarus," that is
painted by Pieter Brueghel.
This and other Brueghels are
referred to in the course of the
poem which proceeds almost as a
kind of imaginary gallery tour
or walk in which Auden as our
companion takes us to different
works and contemplates their
commentary on the general issue
that he is raising here:
what is art's relation to
suffering?
About suffering they were
never wrong,
The Old Masters:
how well they understood
Its human position [he's
concerned with how you position
suffering in
human life, and he's taking
Brueghel as a model];
how it takes place
While someone else is eating or
opening a window or just walking
dully
along [as this line of poetry
itself seems to];
How, when the aged are
reverently, passionately waiting
For the miraculous birth [now
he's contemplating a Nativity
scene], there
must always be
Children who did not specially
want it to happen,
skating
On a pond at the edge of the
wood:
They never forgot [the old
masters]
That even the dreadful
martyrdom [and now he's looking
at Brueghel's
painting "The Massacre of the
Innocents"]
must run its course
Anyhow in a corner,
some untidy spot
Where the dogs go on with their
doggy life and the torturer's
horse [no
more innocent or guilty than
those boys, I suppose]
Scratches its innocent behind
on a tree.
The Old Masters know the human
position of suffering,
its position in human life.
"Position" is important;
it's an important word for
Auden here.
He's concerned with how
experience is placed.
Sometimes he calls this
geography.
It is a topos,
a motif, and an idea in his
poetry that Elizabeth Bishop
will take over quite directly
from him and develop and make
central to her poetry.
The idea is that things have
meaning in relation to,
in their connection with,
but also their separation from
each other.
Suffering is part,
but only a part and not the
center of human life,
a repertoire of actions and
conditions and states of being
that is much larger.
In Brueghel,
in his "Massacre of the
Innocents" – I won't try to
find it now among my slides for
you--Auden focuses on the
"torturer's horse,"
the animal that is part of the
scene and that motivated by an
itch, scratches its behind while
the dreadful martyrdom runs its
course.
In this poem,
as in other Auden poems,
note the prose rhythms.
The poem does seem to at times
walk dully along.
Auden, like Moore,
is writing in an expository
manner, I guess an essayistic
manner.
This is part of the tone of the
poem.
Auden is getting into his
poetry a kind of neo-classical,
eighteenth-century aesthetic,
an ability to talk about ideas
in poetry in,
again, a discursive,
expository manner that includes
humor and that is
matter-of-fact,
is observant.
Pain, like the tears that I
talked about last time that had
dried on Auden's pages,
pain is part of the picture,
but it is just a part.
It's, in a sense,
been put aside.
All of this is a function of
what I'm calling Auden's
perspectivism.
Any scene borders on other
scenes where other people are
positioned looking at the same
thing differently or not looking
at it at all.
And this is one of the themes
of the second section of the
poem where Auden specifically
describes this painting.
He says: In Brueghel's
Icarus,
for instance….
And this is a poetry in which
the poet says "for instance,"
just as Moore might have said
"however."
how everything turns away
Quite leisurely from the
disaster….
And he's talking about the
shepherd who's looking up to the
sky, he's talking about the
ploughman who has his back
turned to the fall;
and where is it?
It's hard probably for you to
see, but it's hard to find in
any case because this dramatic
event that is the center of
Brueghel's pictures – in fact,
these bare legs disappearing
into the sea as the overreaching
son of Daedalus plunges into the
water – is not at all in the
center of the picture.
how everything turns away
[Auden observes]
Quite leisurely from the
disaster;
the ploughman may
Have heard the splash,
the forsaken cry,
But for him it was not an
important failure.…
He's not concerned with flying
to or beyond the sun.
For him the sun merely shines,
it helps him cultivate the
land.
the sun shone [of
necessity]
As it had to on the white legs
disappearing into the green
Water [the white legs
water];
and the expensive delicate ship
that must have seen
Something amazing,
a boy falling out of the sky,
Had somewhere to get to and
sailed calmly on.
Well, here Auden wasn't
thinking about Hart Crane,
but he might have been.
It's almost as if this figure
has leaped off the back of the
boat, as Crane did.
He is, however,
thinking, I suppose,
about romanticism in general
and its ambitions.
Here, the sun shines as it had
to.
What it illuminates are white
legs.
There's a kind of objectivity
in that, there's a kind of
naturalism.
It shines on green water.
It's as if from a certain
perspective, from the
perspective of aesthetic form,
these elements of the picture
are merely elements of the
picture – colors,
which have meaning as they are
placed in a system of
relationships and a system of
perspectives.
Well, there's a great deal more
to be said about this painting.
I think one idea that is worth
emphasizing is the way in which
the ploughman,
in Auden's account as in
Brueghel's painting,
has prominence,
has a greater prominence than
the heroic,
romantic figure plunging into
the sea.
The ploughman is going about
his ordinary daily work,
and as he turns these furrows,
we are reminded,
as Auden surely was reminded,
of the ancient classical
connection between verse –
meaning the turning,
in Latin, from one line to
another – and the shaping
action of the plough that
creates these furrows in the
earth,
committing the poet,
as he identifies with the
ploughman, to a kind of poetry
of craft and of the earth that
involves,
in a sense, turning away from
disaster.
Well, this poem was written in
Europe.
It is a poem that Auden – let
me find this picture here –
with which Auden,
in a sense, turns his back on
Europe and, for the moment at
least, the imminent world war.
He comes to the United States;
he immigrates to the United
States in January 1939.
This personal turning point in
a poetic career comes at a
moment when the world is about
to be split in war.
It also comes at a significant
moment in literary history when
Yeats dies, and Auden recognizes
this occasion as a moment to
celebrate the poet,
contemplate the achievement in
modern poetry that he represents
Yeats and, in a sense,
provide a kind of epitaph for a
poetry now in the past and
behind us that positions Auden
in the present.
Let's look at the view of Yeats
and of Yeats's poetry that
emerges here.
The poem extends the questions
of "Musée des Beaux Arts" by
asking not so much what is art's
relation to suffering as what is
the place of art in society
generally,
or poetry in particular?
Auden begins:
He disappeared in the
dead of winter:
The brooks were frozen,
the air-ports almost deserted,
And snow disfigured the public
statues;
The mercury sank in the mouth
of the dying day.
Oh, all the instruments agree
The day of his death was a dark
cold day.
There's a sense,
as Auden elaborates these
ideas, that natural science is
here mocking the pathetic
fallacy that all nature should
mourn when the poet dies and
reflect the grief of this event.
He's saying,
Auden is, it was a cold day and
we had instruments to measure it
and that that's what it was,
in a kind of factual way.
He continues, Auden does:
Now he [Yeats]
is scattered among a hundred
cities
And wholly given over to
unfamiliar affections….
…
The words of a dead man
Are modified in the guts of the
living.
Yeats is passed on to us.
And yet to whom has he passed
on?
What difference does he make?
Auden doesn't want us to make
the mistake of thinking that
Yeats is too central a figure,
that he matters too much.
But in the importance and
noise of to-morrow [he
continues]
When the brokers are roaring
like beasts on the floor of the
Bourse,
And the poor have the
sufferings to which they are
fairly accustomed,
And each in the cell of himself
is almost convinced of his
freedom;
A few thousand will think of
this day
As one thinks of a day when one
did something slightly
unusual.
This is an attempt to,
in some sense,
place poetry realistically in
culture.
It doesn't matter to the
brokers "roaring like beasts on
the floor of the Bourse."
It doesn't matter to the poor
who have their suffering "to
which they are fairly
accustomed."
It matters, well,
perhaps to "a few thousand"
people, not a negligible number
but not a large one either.
There's a kind of modesty in
Auden's claims for Yeats,
for poetry.
You could contrast Pound at the
same time as this poem is being
written, broadcasting his ideas
on Fascist radio,
or you could think about
Stevens at the same time
dreaming up a poem he will call
"Notes Toward a Supreme
Fiction."
This is a rather different
claim for what poetry might do.
It returns to a theme of The
Waste Land.
Somehow, the world that Auden
is describing is one in which we
are each imprisoned in the cell
of ourselves,
recalling the locked chambers
of Eliot's poem.
In the second section,
Auden moves to address Yeats
directly.
Now Yeats has,
in a sense, claimed for us his
difference, the vatic powers of
language, the visionary
ambition, and the occult
learning.
All of that that would
distinguish and separate him
from us is put aside,
and what he shares with us is
emphasized:
You were silly like us
[silly]: your gift survived it
all;
[it had to survive a lot,
it had to survive]
The parish of rich women,
[who doted on him,
his own]
physical decay,
Yourself [himself; Auden says];
mad Ireland hurt you into
poetry.
Now Ireland has her madness and
her weather still [you did not
affect it,
you did not affect it because
you are a man and only a man.
In fact],
For poetry makes nothing
happen.…
This is one of the most quoted
sentences in modern poetry:
"poetry makes nothing happen."
It is almost always quoted,
however, out of context.
It is part of a long sentence.
It comes first as a
qualification on what Yeats,
on the difference Yeats has
made in the world.
Auden's saying in a sense,
no, you haven't made a
difference, for poetry makes
nothing happen.
But the poem continues then,
the sentence continues.
Auden says, (colon):
"it survives."
"…Poetry makes nothing
happen: it survives."
Where?
It survives:
In the valley of its
saying where executives
Would never want to tamper,
it flows south
From ranches of isolation and
the busy griefs,
Raw towns that we believe and
die in;
it survives,
A way of happening,
a mouth.
Poetry doesn't make things
happen.
It has a different kind of
action.
It survives;
it lasts.
How does it last,
where does it last?
It lasts "in the valley of its
saying," a kind of imaginary
landscape or a kind of world
that is created through speech
here.
"The valley of its saying":
perhaps a rich place to live
but also a space that evokes a
kind of absence or hollow,
right?
Or a kind of opening perhaps,
or a gap.
As Auden develops this idea the
poetry becomes what he calls "a
way of happening,
a mouth."
And then that valley is
refigured as a mouth – an open
mouth, I'm sure,
a mouth open where words are
coming out,
where more words will follow
and flow like a kind of river.
Poetry, in that sense,
doesn't make anything happen.
It is rather a way of
happening, that is,
a kind of method or model,
a path or discipline:
a way.
Not a deed, but something more
like the symbol of a deed or the
figure of a kind of potential
action,
a nothing that is somehow
something, too,
again, I think,
an image implying an open
mouth;
that is, the mouth of a river
or the mouth of a poet,
through which language flows.
Then the poem moves into,
I think, a kind of illustration
of the kind of action that
poetry engages in,
and that comes with the
movement into these ceremonial
quatrains in iambic tetrameter,
essentially.
Is that what it is?
Well, it's definitely a
tetrameter.
The rhyme enters.
The prose rhythms of the poem
up to now give way to a kind of
ceremonial lyric language.
Here poetry is identified with
praise and with prayer.
The poem gives us a kind of
performative language of human
ceremony that honors Yeats,
that lays him to rest and yet
also absorbs and affirms the
power of poetry that was in him.
Earth,
receive an honoured guest;
William Yeats is laid to rest.
Let the Irish vessel lie
Emptied of its poetry.
Auden goes on to describe the
way that time will honor poetry
and will honor Yeats;
that time will even,
he says – Auden does –
forgive Yeats for the right-wing
politics that Yeats's later
career is marked by and that
Auden separates himself from and
needs to come to terms with in
this poem.
He says:
Time with this strange
excuse
Pardoned Kipling and his views,
And will pardon Paul Claudel
[Kipling, for his imperial
jingoism, Claudel
for his proto-Fascist ideas],
Pardons him [Yeats also]
for writing well.
Auden, looking back on this
poem, would ask himself,
how could I possibly presume to
judge Yeats and forgive him
morally for his politics?
And he struck these
condescending lines from his
poem.
So, you won't find them in
The Collected Poems but
you will find the powerful lines
that proceed from them.
In the nightmare of the
dark
All the dogs of Europe bark,
And the living nations wait,
Each sequestered in its hate;
Intellectual disgrace
Stares from every human face,
And the seas of pity lie
Locked and frozen in each
eye.
What does the poet do in this
condition?
Follow, poet, follow right
To the bottom of the
night….
The poet descends and descends
into night, a night that is this
nightmare in which Europe barks,
ready to attack itself.
With your unconstraining
voice
Still persuade us to rejoice;
With the farming of a verse
[and remember the ploughman now,
as a figure for the poet]
Make a vineyard of the curse,
Sing of human unsuccess
In a rapture of distress;
In the deserts of the heart
Let the healing fountains start,
In the prison of his days
Teach the free man how to
praise.
This is what poetry can offer.
It can offer a lesson in how to
praise.
This is not making something
happen politically in the world,
perhaps, but it's making
something happen in the heart
and perhaps within the eye of
each of us who look locked and
staring with our pity,
frozen there.
Poetry would be a kind of
farming in the desert of the
heart that would break open that
which is locked there and free
feeling.
It's a powerful and very
traditional claim for what poems
can do.
And in talking about The
Waste Land,
I stressed the ways in which
Eliot sought language of public
ritual that might join people
separated in the cells of
themselves.
Here, Auden is working through
the same ideas and providing a
kind of model for how that might
work.
Let me turn ahead with you to
another great poem from this
period, "In Memory of Sigmund
Freud."
Freud is a kind of ploughman.
He is another model for the
poet, for Auden.
And this poem proposes still
other ways to understand
poetry's relation to suffering,
represented here by Freud's
humanistic, therapeutic
technique.
What sort of hero is Freud?
Auden calls him "an important
Jew who died in exile."
It's significant that he is
called that by Auden at this
moment.
If you look for the figure of
the Jew in "Gerontion," Eliot's
early poem, you'll see that the
figure is not dignified with a
capital J.
Anti-Semitism is a crisis in
Europe and it's certainly a
pervasive current in modern
poetry.
Whether it is actually a theme
or a motif, as it appears in
Eliot or Pound,
or simply a kind of voluble
prejudice as you would find it
in Williams's letters,
anti-Semitism is powerful.
And here, Auden is identifying
himself with Freud as a Jew and
as a Jew in exile.
And it seems as though Freud in
this way represents a figure for
people who are in some sense
extracted from the nation and
who are international in their
perspective.
And Auden himself is writing in
America from a similar point of
view.
As in the Yeats elegy,
Auden is reluctant to single
Freud out when,
as he says, death is so common
and suffering is so common.
But Freud's point of view for
Auden is powerful and valuable
precisely because it emphasizes
the commonplaceness of human
suffering, its ubiquity.
He's praised – Freud is –
as the poem unfolds,
specifically for the ways in
which he responds to suffering.
How does he do it?
Well, around line 28 or so,
on page 804,
Auden says:
All that he did was to
remember
Like the old and be honest like
children.
He wasn't clever at all [he was
silly like us]:
he merely told
The unhappy Present to recite
the Past
Like a poetry lesson till sooner
Or later it faltered at the
line where
Long ago the accusations had
begun,
And suddenly knew by whom it
had been judged,
How rich life had been and how
silly [there's that word again],
And was life-forgiven and more
humble,
…
No wonder the ancient cultures
of conceit
In his technique of
unsettlement [that's what he
(Auden) calls Freud's
therapeutic technique,
the talking cure:
it's a technique of
unsettlement]
The fall of princes,
the collapse of
Their lucrative patterns of
frustration.
If he had succeeded [Freud],
why, the Generalised Life
Would become impossible,
the monolith
Of State be broken and prevented
The co-operation of avengers.
Of course they called on God
[his (Freud's) detractors]:
but he went his
way [like the poet who follows
right to the bottom of the
night],
Down among the Lost People like
Dante, down
To the stinking fosse where the
injured
Lead the ugly life of the
rejected.
And showed us what evil is:
not as we thought
Deeds that must be punished,
but our lack of faith,
Our dishonest mood of denial,
The concupiscence of the
oppressor.
Auden emphasizes Freud's
literary dimensions.
The talking cure is like a
poetry lesson.
It puts faith in speech,
in the powers of true speech,
to correct and reshape and heal
human life.
It is a technique of
unsettlement that is a threat to
princes, all worldly authority,
because it questions authority
and empowers the individual
speaker to take life into his
hands.
Like Dante or like Pound's
Ulysses in Canto I,
like the poet at the end of the
Yeats elegy,
Freud, in Auden's poem,
goes down among the lost people
and goes into "the stinking
fosse,"
which is a powerful word.
It's a word that appears in
Canto I where Ulysses,
Pound's Ulysses,
goes to seek Tiresias.
"Fosse," it's an Anglo-Saxon
word.
It reaches back,
in that sense,
in cultural history to suggest
that our present misery is one
with, continuous with,
that of the past.
And yet history is something
here that can be intervened in,
in an individual way through
the kind of true speech that
Auden celebrates in Freud and
that he aspires to in poetry.
As the elegy builds towards its
conclusion, on page 806,
again the night appears.
Freud:
… would have us
remember most of all
To be enthusiastic over the
night [and its lost people,
ourselves]
Not only for the sense of wonder
It alone has to offer [night,
the unconscious],
but also
Because it needs our love:
for with sad eyes
Its delectable creatures look
up and beg
Us dumbly to ask them to
follow….
That is, all the properties
here of the unconscious that are
identified at the same time with
all those who are lost in
society and need to be
represented and claimed.
They are, like Freud:
…exiles who long for
the future
That lies in our power.
[Again a power of speech.]
They too would rejoice
If allowed to serve
enlightenment like him [like
Freud],
Even to bear our cry of "Judas,"
As he did and all must bear who
serve it.
Freud here is in exile,
and he brings insight but he
also brings love.
Auden is imagining a kind of
general state of homelessness,
which Freud's technique of
unsettlement isn't meant to
redress but rather to recognize
and accept and help us adjust to
and live in.
Auden's own technique here
is--well, his verse form is a
simple syllable count:
11 syllables,
9 syllables,
10.
The normative ten-syllable line
comes last and fourth and gives
a kind of resolution to each
quatrain.
This simple pattern,
again, accommodates and
promotes a kind of prose speech,
a kind of ordinariness that
identifies Freud's work and the
poet's work with a kind of
ordinary,
ongoing work and that
accommodates rationality in a
rational voice,
as Auden will describe Freud's
as being,
and yet also accommodates
feeling at the same time and
accommodates love.
One rational voice is
dumb [Freud's,
he's silent]:
over a grave [his grave]
The household of Impulse mourns
one dearly loved [because he
understood how to love our
impulses].
Sad is Eros, builder of cities,
And weeping anarchic
Aphrodite.
It's eventually a powerful,
moving conclusion.
Eros and Aphrodite have lost
their champion.
I'm going to conclude by
commenting very quickly,
since we're almost out of time,
on one last poem,
arguably Auden's greatest,
"In Praise of Limestone," a
poem written from the
perspective of the post-war in
the United States,
but about a kind of imaginary
landscape that combines elements
of his childhood – a landscape
in northern England – and the
Italian landscape where he
returned in the post-War period
and became increasingly attached
to.
It is a kind of allegorical
space and it represents a home,
I suppose, for the homeless,
for we, "the inconstant ones,"
as he describes us.
It is, this limestone
landscape, something to be
praised, and it is a poem of
praise.
It is an image of the world
without another transcendental
world beyond or behind it.
To be in the world,
as described in this poem,
is to be in an entirely earthly
realm.
And again, you might think of
the ploughman turning away from
the over-reacher who tried to
fly to the sky and turns rather
to the earth.
It is a landscape like that of
Stevens in "Sunday Morning."
It is a landscape that Auden
can only describe as a kind of
imaginary place through
counter-factual statements.
It is porous.
It's rich, it's fertile,
and it's moderate.
It is not a place of extremes;
and hermits and Caesars;
they don't belong here.
They go elsewhere.
It's rather a place in which
ordinary life and ordinary
people might live.
The very end of the poem is
extremely powerful because it
looks towards a kind of redeemed
human life,
sees it in this landscape,
and yet represents it in the
conditional.
Auden says--this is on page
808:
In so far as we have to
look forward
To death as a fact [something
he will never let us forget],
no doubt we
are right: But if
Sins can be forgiven,
if bodies rise from the dead
[and you note the
conditional in both phrases],
These modifications of matter
into
Innocent athletes [the people
that he peoples this landscape
with]
and
gesticulating fountains,
Made solely for pleasure,
make a further point:
The blessed will not care what
angle they are regarded from,
Having nothing to hide.
Dear [and now he speaks to a
beloved], I know
nothing of
Either [that is,
what it would mean to be
blessed or to have nothing to
hide: I know nothing of either
of those things],
but when I try to imagine a
faultless love
Or the life to come,
what I hear is the murmur
Of underground streams,
what I see is a limestone
landscape.
A landscape that is Auden's
version of an earthly paradise
and our only image of these
ultimate promises.
Auden manages somehow here to
make us see and feel what the
life to come might be like,
what it might be like to be
blessed, while still
acknowledging that we can only
live in and be in and speak in
the world before us,
which is the one that Auden
remains, throughout his poetry,
dedicated to.
Well, we'll go on to a poet
closely identified with Auden,
Elizabeth Bishop,
on Wednesday.